JOSH HAWLEY: You've
referred to people
with a capacity for pregnancy.
Would that be women?
KHIARA BRIDGES: Many
women, cis women,
have the capacity for pregnancy.
Many cis women do not have
the capacity for pregnancy.
There are also trans men who
are capable of pregnancy,
as well as non-binary people
who are capable of pregnancy.
[music playing]
JOSH HAWLEY: So this isn't
really a women's rights issue.
It's a what?
KHIARA BRIDGES: We can
recognize that this
impacts women while
also recognizing
that it impacts other groups.
Those things are not mutually
exclusive, Senator Hawley.
JOSH HAWLEY: So your view is
that the core of this right,
then, is about what?
KHIARA BRIDGES: So
I want to recognize
that your line of
questioning is transphobic,
and it opens up trans
people to violence
by not recognizing them.
JOSH HAWLEY: Wow.
You're saying that I'm
opening up people to violence
by asking whether or not
women are the folks who
can have pregnancies?
KHIARA BRIDGES: So I'm--
I want to note that one out
of five transgender persons
have attempted suicide.
So I think it's
important for us--
JOSH HAWLEY: Because of
my line of questioning?
KHIARA BRIDGES: --because--
JOSH HAWLEY: So we
can't talk about it?
KHIARA BRIDGES: --because
denying that trans people exist
and pretending not to know
that they exist is dangerous.
JOSH HAWLEY: I'm denying that
trans people exist by asking--
KHIARA BRIDGES: Are you?
JOSH HAWLEY: --you if
you're talking about women--
KHIARA BRIDGES: Are you?
Are you?
JOSH HAWLEY:
--having pregnancies?
KHIARA BRIDGES: Do you believe
that men can get pregnant?
JOSH HAWLEY: No, I don't
think men can get pregnant.
KHIARA BRIDGES:
So you are denying
that trans people exist.
Thank you.
JOSH HAWLEY: And that
leads to violence.
Is this how you
run your classroom?
Are students allowed
to question you--
KHIARA BRIDGES: Absolutely.
JOSH HAWLEY: --or are they also
treated like this, where you--
KHIARA BRIDGES: No, no, no.
They're allowed to question.
JOSH HAWLEY: --they're
told that they're opening
up people to violence--
KHIARA BRIDGES: Oh, we have
a good time in my class.
JOSH HAWLEY: --by questioning.
KHIARA BRIDGES: You should join.
JOSH HAWLEY: Oh, I bet.
KHIARA BRIDGES: You
might learn a lot.
JOSH HAWLEY: Wow.
I would learn a lot.
I've learned a lot--
KHIARA BRIDGES: You-- I know.
JOSH HAWLEY: --just
from this exchange.
KHIARA BRIDGES: Absolutely.
JOSH HAWLEY: Extraordinary.
KHIARA BRIDGES: Yep.
[music playing]
[cnn jingle]